[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قديما كان العرب يبداون بالتنقل والترحل
والتفرق للبحث عن مواطن الكلا مع دخول
موسم الوسم كحالي ايامنا هذه وحنه نبدا
نختار الاماكن وننصب الخيام ليش حتى
نستمتع بالاجواء الجميله والتي تدوم معنا
لمده اربعه شهور تقريبا ومع دخول موسم
الصيف يرجع العرب الى قرارهم حول موارد
المياه وحنا الى منازلنا فهم يتفرقون ونحن
نجتمع مع دخول موسم ونحن نتفرق وهم
يجتمعون مع دخول موسم الكنه كونوا جميعا
يا بني
ولا تتفرقوا احاده كعب الرماح اذا اجتمعنا
تكسرا واذا افترقنا تكسرت
افراد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعرب القدماء يعرفون بدايه الاجواء
الجميله بمقارنه القمر اجمل نجوم السماء
بثريا فاذا وقعت ثريا بجانب القمر يوم
الحادي عشر من الشهر الهجري قالوا للحر
وجميع مواسمه مع السلامه واذا وقع القمر
بجانب الثريا في اليوم الاول من الشهر
الهجري قالوا جاءكم الحر مع سمومه هبت
رياح الصيف وتغير الجو وانا وليفي ما
يداني سمومه يا شمس طيبي واختفي من وراء
نوم لا تشرقي يا شمس كوني رحومه
[موسيقى]